STEVE: Hello.
We're going to talk about three very important
things as signified by this very important-looking
slide: the 1990s, JavaScript, and style sheets.
As if that wasn't totally clear.
My name is Steve Kinney.
I have this very unique Twitter handle, where
you can hear me complain about the current
members of Blink 182.
If you want to come visit Colorado this summer,
and see Tom and see Monica, a bunch of people
you saw this weekend, see them again, we will
have the encore presentation in Denver on
15 and 6 June.
Talking about teaching or learning or that
kind of stuff, please come and find me afterwards.
Right now, I'm a certain front end engineer
at SendGrid.
If you ever got a receipt from Uber -
I work on the marketing emails client which
means I take arbitrary user mark-up in CSS
and then try to create a drag-and-drop editor
and then try to make something that works
in L2007.
It is a wonderful platform.
If you thought IE6 was rough, outlook said
outlook, hold my beer.
It uses Word's rendering engine.
If you want to talk about conditional tags
and table-based layouts, come and talk to
me after this.
I worked on a book called Electron in Action.
Our story starts today in the year 1996.
The best part about doing a slight check from
the 1990s is you can use the animations you
never thought possible and taste goes out.
Let's remember what it was like in 1996.
The popular cellphone at the time did not
have a head phone Jack.
We walked around with digital pets.
We neglected the digital pets.
We cloned a sheep and the Beatles.
And this happened.
Rachel gave us a taste yesterday of some of
the wonderment that was the web in the 1990s
from a very cultural standpoint.
I myself was a web developer at age 12 and
made a website of Mortal Combat cheap codes.
I had a bunch of animated gifs for no reason.
Little to no concern for accessibility.
It took about three minutes to download the
assets and played a music file without the
user's content - like the web pages in 2017!
I did find this Doom website which is pretty
much my aesthetic at the time.
Just imagine everything Doom-like with the
same background, divider bar, everything along
those lines.
So mother just - some other other websites
at the time on geocities that you could find
- yes, Bobby, you do!
It had a midi file which was great.
I.
The way you made websites was you took your
styles and inlined them with style tags.
You kept going as you went at every subsequent
tag if the background colour needed to change.
If we wanted to have a marquee with a different
background colour, you could do that.
You laugh at the marquee tag.
This is what I write in my job now which is
table-based layouts.
I still live in this world, and I know it
very well.
This is not a retrospective for me, it is
like my day to day.
You laugh at the marquee magazine.
It still works in Chrome today.
It can be used, if that is the designer aesthetic
that you're going for.
The page got on a web ring.
That was great.
I got listed on a sub directory on Yahoo and
you might say a web ring, who needs more than
one mortal code cheat code website?
I was 12.
Try to stay on topic and focus.
Keep that in mind next time you might want
to write a think piece about JavaScript fatigue!
So the hit counter hit 100, which is very
impressive considering that I was paying by
minute so it was time for a redesign.
Going through and updating the tags can pest
be described in this stock photograph.
To give you a sense for those who didn't have
to update a page from the 1990s, it was like
migrating from one version of Angular to the
next!
Luckily, there were frames so you had isolated
components that you could cash with their
own style.
Again, you laugh but still supported in Chrome.
The things that, the - some of the style sheets
today existed at the time but I was unaware
of them.
The first web browser, the one developed at
CERN by Tim Berners-Lee - you might know him
as a web developer! - actually had support
for this thing called style sheets.
There wasn't a formal shared syntax but the
browser itself supported this idea that you
could define what all the styles should look
like.
In fact, the voila browser was one of the
first browsers to implement this and ship
it.
It is very hard to find screen shots from
the early 1990s, by the way.
Mosaic browser took a step back and didn't
allow users to use style sheets.
I noticed that Mosiac renders something different
than links and I wonder if I can have any
control over that.
To which the response was, "In fact, it has
been a constant source of delight for me over
the past year to tell hordes of people who
want to strap themselves and control the way
your document that would be trivial in every
other common text processing environment.
Sorry, you're screwed.".
the idea of style sheets was that the browser
could have some say what an-1 should look
like in a paragraph.
Ideally, the user could do that until someone
sent a reset CSS in there.
Netscape supported this, still in modern browsers
like Firefox.
There was a third group of people who wanted
a say over their style at the time.
Authors like yourself and people like me with
important Mortal Combat web pages.
Not to say these people could be trusted.
This is a website I designed in 2004.
So there is no accounting for taste when people
got access to these style sheets.
There were as many ten different implementations
of style sheets at the time.
We will talk about two of them - CSS and JavaScript
style sheets.
There was no logo for, and found fair to grasp
the worst possible logo for CSS.
They came about in Netscape 4.0.
That was the only time they were seen in the
wild.
Let's look what these style sheets look like.
Let's leave, and here we go.
We have a modern web browser, and some mark-up.
So there is some tasting notes here.
You will notice that we have a link, a still
sheet link, but it goes to this JS immediately
of a CSS.
That is the first clue that you might be using
JavaScript style sheets.
After that, we have some very non-exciting
mark-up, careful readers will notice the "segum
ipsum", a little bit of form along those lines.
One thing that I learned along the way is
that there was no document.element.get.id
yet.
In fact, Netscape through away the DOM after
it rendered it and showed the original version
there so it limited a lot what you could do
at the time.
Let's play around with it a second.
We can see that there is nothing right now
but we could theoretically write, "Document.
Tags H1."
Colour is red.
Cool.
Let's go ahead and refresh that.
And you see that there are lovely H1 turns
red.
Other things that we might want to do.
For instance, in the notes, they said make
sure that your fonts are 24 pixels so everyone
can see them.
Let's put that in as well.
You can see we can style individual tags.
So then, I know CSS, right?
I don't want to use dots for classes, how
do we do that?
We had a slightly different way of doing that.
We could say document - and the document was
actually arbitrary, it was window, it was
a global at the time.
We could say classes and we could say I believe
that it was called first, our first paragraph.
You have to say what kind of tag that would
be.
You could say a P and then you could say background
colour, weee!
Equals green.
I don't know, why not?
We've seen my taste already.
It can't hurt.
Save that.
This editor is from the 1990s.
It is not funny!
If you wanted to get everything with a class
at first, which is the only one, you could
say Al-tags in this situation.
Cool - all tags in this situation.
JavaScript style sheets had other interesting
things.
They had variables.
So I could say bar colour is equal to green,
and I could use that as well.
All right.
And you can see that works as well.
We had variables, all the JavaScript programming
language available to us.
You could even, if you really wanted to, add
a little bit of uncertainty to your web page,
right?
You could say, "Hey, give me a random number
and round it to 0 or 1 and use in a as the
background colour of the page."
Sometimes it would be black and sometimes
white.
You could set the variables and use it altogether.
You could say do you want to implement a dark
mode which was very popular in like 2010.
Go ahead and do that as well.
And now if it was in dark mode, you got these
different colours versus if that was not set
to true.
In fact, you could do some interesting things
because you had stuff like "confirm" so you
could ask the user did they want to go back
to dark mode, and you could style it based
on user input.
If writing tags and documents every time was
too verbose, we could go ahead and use everyone's
friend, the "with" key word in JavaScript
and get the same basic effect as well.
There were some interesting things you could
do as well where the page was evaluated - it's
hard to tell because I don't have any dev
tools and there are no events or anything
like that, but here we will say, when this
style sheet loads, let's measure the inner
width, and, if it is less than 600, let's
make the background colour red otherwise make
it blue.
Like the early-days media queries.
Here we go.
If I grab the edge of this - can he grab the
edge - let's grab this corner down here.
You can see we have the beginnings of responsive
design in 1995 when you would have been looking
at your Motorola Star Tech.
There are fun things that we could have done
in this land.
Like the web itself wasn't ready for the sheer
awesomeness that the style sheets would behold,
like vendor pre-fixes.
But imagine or something like "view with"
and create our own extra units.
We had the full power of a programming language
to figure out how we style things.
Cool.
That done includes our live coding portion
of the show.
There were still things, like specificity,
right?
You weren't getting away from that one.
It followed the same rules that it did back
- we will talk about that in a second.
There was a submission to the W3C to make
it part of a spec and it never came to be,
so there were some things that were in the
spec that didn't actually work in Netscape
sparse I can tell.
One interesting one was "evaluate style" and
you're, "Where's the function key word?
I likely don't know.
I've tried it with and without."
You could use functions to evaluate based
on other parts of the style sheet what another
style should be.
Why you would use it in this case, I don't
know.
But there it is.
Then you're going to apply it to all sorts
of different things.
People were very excited about this.
The big thing about JSSS is you could change
the colour and font size based on user interaction.
Spoiler alert: this is something we're still
chasing now.
So, the - we all know how the story ends.
CSS was adopted by Internet Explorer 3 and
accepted as a standard to the W3C.
Your options were you could in Netscape write
JSSS or JavaScript style sheets, now logo,
before you could only write in CSS.
People made the obvious choice and just used
CSS.
It turned out Netscape thought JSSS would
be the be all and end all and the - it just
shelled out to the JavaScript - implement
style sheets ultimately came to a close like
the Fresh Prince of Bel Air.
They were removed - there were a lot of missed
opportunity here.
What if throughout the kind of today we could
have used Modernizr to do feature detections
and have an ultimate style sheet on the fly
and have a style sheet to figure out how to
move back to more supported properties?
You can imagine this is fictitious code, you
can imagine a world where we had code-split
CSS files or JavaScript style sheet fliers
and loaded on the fly based on the user navigating
or taking a given action.
You could theoretically do this based on user
action, right, if you had to interrupt.
In my experimentation, if you put a variable
on the window object, you could access in
your JavaScript later on.
It didn't work the other way.
Again, I don't fully know why.
In this fictitious perfect world, we can see
a world where we can all of a sudden have
interaction between JavaScript and our styles.
So as I said, JavaScript style sheets didn't
make it, but like a bunch of ideas like really
half-kept cropping up over and over and over
again over the years.
Sass and Less gave us functions, and variables,
and conditionals.
These were like a powerful way in the way
we style things today.
jQuery even took this idea of finding by a
selector and being able to manipulate the
way something looked to another level as well.
CSS4 brought us variables, and even some functions
like calc.
These are ideas, that even though they didn't
survive in the first iteration, they were
ones that we looked at again and again.
All of these, CSS4 aside, have some limitations.
A very handsome man once drew the line between
static analysis and dynamic analysis.
We couldn't run a style sheet because we came
up with a random number.
We don't have that introspection we had potentially
with the real JavaScript style sheets or my
fictitious examples earlier.
We do have a little bit of access with the
thing called the CSS object model which you
may or may not have ever heard of.
It is very cool but kind of incomplete.
Basically, you open up your Chrome developer
tools and go to document.style sheets, you
can access all the style sheets that have
been loaded by the browser, look at their
rules, insert and delete rules, on the fly.
It is really cool but it has some limitations
- one, cross-origin sheets.
Two, there is no real way to traverse it.
It is an example where you can navigate through,
and you could iterate it is an array-like
object so you could loop over it and will
give you the amazing effect as we change the
background colour of the body on a said interval.
We could theoretically implement some of those
fake ideas from the JavaScript style sheet,
but it's the under-specced so not clear how
it works every time on every producer so generally
speaking, not our best option.
We don't have the tools to work with it.
All browsers come with a DOM parser that let's
us manipulate.
We could use post-CSS read the style tag and
use the stuff at run time, but it doesn't
work out so great.
As our craft has developed, we've taken this
giant document viewer and our craft as evolved.
JavaScript developers have taken on these
different live techniques.
It turns out an object that has its own property
doesn't work out in Netscape Navigator 4.
By walking this code of how were to implement
stuff, we've been able to kind of move the
web forward, but we mate our tools better,
and eventually, we made the platform better.
I think really strongly the way we've made
JavaScript such an amazing platform is doing
things we were not supposed to do, working
around the hard parts, automating that work
and eventually fixing the platform itself.
As we come to this component-based approach
where everything is isolated and encapsulated,
we decided that it is CSS that is limiting
us at this point.
And there are some really good points to this,
right?
All styles are in the global scope.
It is tricky to figure out dependencies, sharing
constants unless you're like me on Ruby on
Rails in 2010 - REBs things into your templates
- don't do that! - these are big problems.
Like writing over another style.
You know, it is very mutable, whatever comes
last wins in a lot of cases.
I know that people who knew CSS really well
were arguing this this pain don't seem the
same thing.
I would always take pause when we find ourselves
with somebody who knows something more than
I do doesn't see the problem in the same way.
I thought a lot about this.
I came from Ruby originally, and a few years
ago, it was not too uncommon to see things
like this.
And you had to ask yourself a question: are
we falling the same trap, right?
We said JavaScript couldn't be used to build
robust web applications.
So, as we find ourselves saying that CSS is
broken, I think that that is a trap of the
way we think about these things.
JavaScript obviously can be used to build
applications, it has been used, even some
of those posts have recanted since then, and
I wonder if we need to think about that in
terms of our relationship with CSS?
Because CSS does - you know, it does have
its rough edges.
But who amongst us does not!
This is CSS Sudden Garden with different mark-up
and style sheets can transform an application
in amazing ways.
This is in a response to the previous quote
saying like, "Hey, maybe we don't want to
couple the way our applications look, we can
parse everything into our components but what
happens when it comes to change the font across
the entire page because marketing" right?
Why why throw the baby out of the bathwater.
There are some troublesome parts in CSS but
also some great parts.
We can't inline our styles because we have
a marionette and along with a WordPress site.
Right, so I think a lot about this graph.
I think we've solved some of it with build
tools.
We have style lint in post-CSS, allowing us
to build up a style sheet in imports across
different files.
We can make sure one style isn't stepping
over another one with immutable CSS.
As far as the encapsulation, we have standards
we're working towards to solve these problems
that don't throw out CSS in the process.
I think about the static and dynamic analysis
we talked about yesterday.
Some of the things I like to see in the platform
is improved cycle time, better inside nexus
at run time, right?
When I was kind of like - one of the things
that means the most to me in terms of developing
the platform is the single extensible web
manifesto, which some people have signed,
and it is this idea that we can, the low-level
APIs allowing people to build ideas, and give
greater insight and access to the platform
itself, right, and make a few more features
than we want to see and look at those kind
of paths and see what we advance the platform
into being.
You saw Takeda 39 up here earlier -- you saw
TC39 up here and the process and ways to get
involved as a developer.
The task of Houdini is to expose the same
low-level APIs to us.
Right now, we have access to the DOM, so all
of our solutions involve let's us modify the
DOM.
We have the partial access to the CSS access
model.
There's a lot we don't have access to.
The idea of Houdini is to give us access to
parts of the process that we didn't have access
to previously.
JavaScript style sheets were short-lived,
but there are some ideas that are obviously
carried around over the last 20 years.
Right now would be we are solving problems
with the best tools that we have, but I think
it is exciting to look at what tools we could
have, right?
Thinking about what are we doing now that
we would love the browser to be able to do
for us?
And figuring out, like we want the web platform
to be.
About an hour ago, this quote, which I loved,
"The nice thing about being the last talks
is you can steal everyone else's ideas" is
that standards of community in involvement
are not standards period.
I leave you with this moral of the story:
rather than work around the limitations let's
push for the web platform we want.
Let's work out what we want the browser to
do for us and how interacting with the web,
and let's start making that happen.
Thank you.
[Cheering] [Applause].